the invasion of crimea
started with an information attack news
reports
seemingly designed to turn local
residents against ukraine and towards
russia
so information radiation or information
influence or the narratives or the
information warfare
also influences our hearts and minds
then came the proxy forces
with pro-kremlin biker groups and
volunteers
mobilized to protect ethnic russians
from what they claimed
was a threat posed by ukrainian
nationalists
these facade groups that we were talking
about
kozak's russian community of crimea they
would create the appearance of a local
uprising
finally came the russian forces they're
without markings on their uniforms
they definitely look like some kind of
commandos from
a thriller movie they were a really big
man
properly dressed it did not look like
anything of the local self defense as
they were presented
analysts called them russia's little
green men
though president vladimir putin
initially denied his troops were
involved in the unrest
it created enough of a gray zone
to prevent many western politicians in
early 2014
from fully grasping until it was too
late
what was going on in crimea even as
these russia-backed forces took control
of
airports military sites and the
parliament
a referendum was rushed through in which
residents voted for accession to the
russian federation
i had a feeling that someone actually
crushed my house
turned it over you know and actually uh
put its hand on on a very intimate thing
like personal clothes and stuff
in a matter of weeks the biggest land
grab
in europe since the second world war
took place
with failure shot being fired a
significant victory
for a gray zone operation but these
tactics
of deniable meddling fell short when
tried in eastern ukraine
instead of covert action there was open
fighting
offering a sense of 21st century armed
conflict
where new weapons like drones and cyber
attacks
are combined with more traditional tanks
and rifle fire
evidence of what's at risk when the gray
zone
becomes a war zone
[Music]
my name is deborah haynes i'm the
foreign affairs editor at sky news
and you're listening to my podcast into
the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
in this episode we explore russia's
annexation of crimea
and the conflict in eastern ukraine we
also talk
to the uk's military chief about
operating in the gray zone
and how the armed forces are changing
you know the fact that world war ii came
to an end in 1945
there are now very few people alive who
experienced that and of course the
upshot of that is a lot of people don't
know what war is like
and therefore they don't necessarily
have the same incentives that our
fathers and
grandfathers might have had to manage
the risk
of going to war in the same way general
cynic carter
is the head of the uk's armed forces who
he met
in episode one he joined the army when
he was 18
and has spent the past 44 years in
uniform
so as someone who does understand the
risks involved i don't think
that any of our opponents genuinely want
to go to war in the way that we would
define it
and that's because they are able to
realize their ends to achieve their
objectives
without necessarily going that far and i
think that that's the the smart way that
it's being done
which is why i always say that the real
risk is if
that way of operating or even fighting
ends up leading to a miscalculation what
he means is if hostilities in the gray
zone
or an actual war zone were ever to
escalate
out of control and draw in more
countries
and that's the thing that keeps me in
bed at night worrying is whether
a lot of the sort of quite high octane
activity that's going on in whether it's
libya or syria or the edges of iraq or
yemen
or in the eastern mediterranean or
further afield whether that blows out of
control
and what you end up with is politicians
not necessarily knowing where this is
headed and ending up with an
escalatory set of steps which lead to a
miscalculation
what's the gravest threat to the uk if
any of the conflicts that you see around
the world today
gets out of control or if there is a
misstep
from whichever policy maker is sitting
over the top of the inputs to those
conflicts then
that's where the risk will come from and
of course
weapons have proliferated significantly
you know one of the features of what our
authoritarian rivals have done is to
develop new technologies which they
haven't just kept to themselves they've
diversified it and proliferated it to
their proxies and to their
um their customers and that means that
you've got a world with
far more weaponry in it and including
nuclear weaponry and
of course including biological and
chemical weapons in it than perhaps
we've had for
many years and that means that a
miscalculation could be really rather
horrific if it occurs
do you believe that the the grey zone
can threaten a country
to you know in as dangerous a way as
an armed conflict as in take popular
government now i think they have to be
applied with other tools as well i mean
they're they're very useful
um scene setters and um means of
achieving a you know
a vulnerable state of affairs but of
course what we see russia doing
uh very vividly and we saw this with
little green men in the crimea
and we see it with its use of private
military and security companies
particularly wagner
in countries like libya mozambique and
for that matter syria
is there comes a point probably when you
have to tip the thing over the edge and
that does require
some form of physical capability to be
used
as we've heard over this series attacks
in the gray zone
can be used to weaken a target society
from within
by amplifying divisions boosting the
power of compliant politicians
or eroding trust in government
at the extreme end such tactics can be
used
to soften up your opponent for if you
did then want to launch
some kind of military offensive
and in the same way as advances in
technology
are changing how countries compete in
the gray zone
they're also changing the way armed
forces fight
actual wars when people think about war
they have a 20th century paradigm in
mind where war is about mobilizing
armies navies and air forces invading
the territory of your
opponent and occupying it until you come
to to terms
general sir richard barrens retired from
the military
in 2016. his last job in uniform was as
head of what is now called strategic
command
which we learnt about in episode five
it's the branch of the armed forces
that among other things covers cyber
warfare
general barons knows a lot about what is
referred to
as the fourth industrial revolution it's
basically anything
involving technology from artificial
intelligence
to quantum computing and how that is
changing the way countries fight
in the gray zone and in war zones in the
21st century
if your objective is to break the will
of your opponent
the means will exist in fact exist now
to do that without any form of
territorial invention
so for example if you wanted to break
the uk's will
to contest whatever it is that's at
issue
you you might well attempt to do it
through a combination of
offensive cyber activity difficult and
hopefully getting harder in the future
the use of long range precision
conventional so high explosive not
nuclear missiles
also targeted at critical national
infrastructure
and the effect of those two things cyber
and missiles
amplified through social media to cause
mass concern amongst the civil
population i think that if we were if
the uk was subjected to about two weeks
of missile attacks removing power water
telecoms
cyber attacks that amplify that and add
new harm and social media messaging
telling them that
this is only going to get worse then
we would quickly find that our will to
resist was depleted
and if you did that not a single enemy
boot or plane or ship has
come into your territory well presumably
we could fire back
so presumably we could fire back if we
had the tools to fire back
and in the era of precision long-range
precision long-range precision
conventional missiles we don't have them
we have nuclear missiles which are
clearly not a suitable response to that
sort of
attack let me step in here with a bit of
background to help explain
since the end of the cold war the uk and
much of the rest of the nato military
alliance
effectively took a peace dividend
political leaders
hoped the collapse of the soviet union
kind of meant
peace in our times they reduced defense
budgets
and diverted funding into more
voter-friendly areas
like health and education while the size
of armies navies and air forces shrank
the wars in afghanistan and iraq didn't
really reverse this trend
they just meant remaining resources were
channeled
more into helping soldiers fight
insurgencies than into new technologies
or maintaining capabilities to counter
threats from hostile states
while all that was happening opponents
like china russia and iran were busy
developing weapons
and tactics to be able to defeat the
west's
military dominance and they didn't just
focus
on trying to build better aircraft
carriers fast jets or submarines
they also took an asymmetric approach
just think of the damage a barrage of
super-fast missiles
or a swarm of armed drones could cause
to large
legacy military equipment like warships
or tanks
perhaps coupled with a surge of social
media posts
and videos to amplify the psychological
impact of any attack
it's worth remembering that even when
states do descend
into a real shooting war it's still a
battle
over people's minds as much as their
ability to fight
for the uk in terms of fighting
capabilities
missile defense is a particular weakness
as the government hasn't invested enough
in things like
air defense systems or in developing its
own
hypersonic long-range conventional
missiles
to be able to hit back or to deter so
you can see
u.s and uk military asking for these
missiles because they
concede their potential opponents have
already got them so
maybe we should catch up cyber warfare
is also
changing military calculations if you're
able to get
into your opponent's controls for their
air defense radars
you can fool them into thinking a
missile is incoming
or perhaps jam their ability to spot
something
that really is heading their way so your
cyber resilience has got to be good
enough
that you have complete assurance that
what your
reconnaissance assets are telling you is
the truth
and it's not the picture that your enemy
wishes you to see
and what about the increasing autonomy
of weapons
artificial intelligence or ai responds
much faster to a threat than a human
brain
ever could and that could be vital
to be quick enough to fend off an attack
but this could in theory mean a future
war happening
without a human in the final stage of
the decision-making chain
because they can't react fast enough so
we're used to the idea
that an intercontinental missile will
cross the world in about 40 minutes
and our radars and satellites are good
enough to see the thing being launched
and we'll see the trajectory that
they're flying and in there you've got
time to spot it
to ring up the president or the prime
minister who's got to deal with this and
there's enough time to think about what
are you going to do
not a whole lot of time my guess is
eight to ten minutes
before that missile then reaches the end
of its journey and whatever's going to
happen
uh happens now in the future uh due to
the advent of
hypersonic missiles so missiles that go
somewhere between
five to twenty times the speed of sound
then that time to think about it has
disappeared
completely and you'll only be able to
respond at the speed of ai
so you would have to have complete
confidence in you knew
what the ai was going to do and you
would have tested it through endless
endless scenarios
but the opportunity that existed in the
past for a human to say
i know what the machine is saying that
doesn't feel right let's do something
different
we'll have gone so you could literally
have a conflict that would be over in
a matter of minutes yes because of the
vulnerabilities induced
by the speed at which the attack is
happening whether that's a cyber attack
or a missile attack and how fast could a
missile then travel
from one side of the planet to the other
well uh
at up to 20 times the speed of sound
what now takes
40 minutes is going to take 12 minutes
wow quite scary
yeah the conflict in eastern ukraine
didn't involve hypersonic missiles but
it did see
conventional ukrainian forces
significantly tested
by a combination of attacks via russian
drones and artillery fire
coupled with information and cyber
operations
i had a feeling that someone actually
crushed my house
turned it over you know and actually uh
put its hand on on a very intimate thing
like personal clothes and stuff
amin zapatava is ukraine's first deputy
foreign minister
she's also a crimean tartar an ethnic
minority group
indigenous to the peninsula she was
working as a journalist
in crimea in 2014 when russia invaded
i may assure you that we never expected
this uh
to experience uh this brutal aggression
uh from the country that we used to
think is our strategic partner and
neighbor
and actually the one that claimed to be
a brotherhood nation for ukraine
we still have aggression of russian
federation going on
not only in ukraine with the ongoing
occupation of crimea and the whole bunch
of the consequences like colonization of
uh crimea when from one hand russia has
been uh
creating the conditions when the
citizens of ukraine have to abandon
crimea like myself and thousands of
others ukrainians
and from another hand massively
motivating and bringing
russian citizens to the uh occupied
crimea
and reshaping the demography of crimea
and kind of
putting loyal people to crimea
crimea's status has swapped around over
the centuries
but it became an autonomous republic
within an independent ukraine
following the collapse of the soviet
union the peninsula
still had cultural and historical ties
to russia
with many residents speaking russian
moscow
kept a naval base and thousands of
military personnel
on the territory as part of an agreement
with the government in kiev
but old alliances started to crumble in
2013
when pro-western protesters took to the
streets of the ukrainian capital
to rally against the then president
viktor yanukovych
he just scrapped plans to move ukraine
closer to the european union
instead sticking tight to russia
by february 2014 what became known
as the maidan revolution turned
increasingly violent
as pro-government snipers started firing
on the protesters
well these latest pictures show police
firing at a crowd of protesters in
independence square at least one officer
is said to have died
in today's fighting it's reported that
at least 22 people have now died in new
clashes in ukraine between police and
anti-government protesters this is the
scene in independence square in kiev
then on the 22nd of february the
president's hold on power
suddenly collapsed and he fled
interim leaders friendly towards the
european union
took charge in what russian analysts
claimed
was a cia-backed plot to pull ukraine
away from moscow
as opposed to a genuine grassroots
uprising
ukraine is maybe the first
best example of the hybrid wall sergey
markov
is a political analyst and former member
of the russian parliament
he claims that washington was the
initial grayzone actor in ukraine
not moscow this hybrid war was
of the war of the united states against
ukrainian uh democratic uh
democratical and legal government led by
victory on operation united states
intelligence service
uh organized paramilitary groups of
neo-nazis
who are occupied center of keith
also by
controlling of global media
and partly ukrainian media united states
intelligence service community organized
information war against
legal ukrainian president russia has
never
provided evidence to support these
claims though
and the ukrainian government strongly
rejects them
saying they're part of the
disinformation campaign spread by the
kremlin
as the world's attention was focused on
events in kiev
russia saw an opportunity in crimea the
operation to seize crimea has been held
up by the russian military as the gold
standard of using
information activities to achieve your
objectives without any fighting
kid giles is a russia expert from the
think tank chatham house
who we've heard from in earlier episodes
because what the russians did
over the days leading up to that
intervention in crimea was gradually
take control of all of the traditional
media in crimea to television press
radio and so on
and then when they launched the
operation the first step was to take
over the internet
exchange point in the capital simvaropol
and the cable connections
telecommunications cable connections to
the mainland in order to ensure that
russia actually had
complete control over all the
information coming
into and out of the peninsula so nobody
in crimea had any other sources of
information than what the russians were
telling them
and that's been presented as a key
ingredient in this
amazing achievement that russia did of
taking over crimea with barely
a few shots fired and only one fatality
and that was an accident
drumming up support to break away from
ukraine
russian state-backed news reports
described the interim government in kiev
as a fascist junta sergey markov
accuses what he describes as an illegal
hunter
of repression and attempting the
de-russification of ukraine
people in crimea appraisal against
illegal
uh junta which grabbed power
in the february of 2014
and who started uh massive
repression against the political
opponents
and uh had the plan
of violence or diversification
of the ukraine a decision by the
ukrainian parliament
to repeal legislation that gave the
russian language an official status in
ukraine
was seized upon by pro-kremlin voices
to fan fears that kiev planned to
trample
on the rights of russian speakers in
crimea
pro-kremlin activists started to
mobilize
as did russian troops in crimea as well
as special forces
secretly brought in from the russian
mainland the special operations soldiers
didn't wear any badges to betray their
nationality
pretending instead to be local
self-defense
forces though few in ukraine were fooled
can you remember what you thought when
you first saw these
um little green men as people kind of
described them the russian troops
without the insignia
well they they definitely look like some
kind of commandos
from uh from a thriller movie
they were really big men properly
dressed
it did not look like anything of a local
self-defense as they were presented
is from ukraine but she lives in london
and works as a research fellow
at the chatham house think tank these
facade groups
that we were talking about kozak's
russian community of crimea they would
create the appearance of a local
uprising
they took control of airports military
bases
and other infrastructure including the
parliament building
under the guise of seeking to protect
ethnic russians
but of course when they put the russian
flag on the ukrainian parliament
um and they started dispatching some of
more violent uh groups they used it to
put down the pro-ukrainian protest to
make people afraid go on the streets for
example to
support kiev the authorities in kiev
appeared reluctant to respond with force
to what was unfolding in crimea
fearful of making the situation worse
thousands of ukrainian troops were
stationed on the territory at the time
most refused to defect even when
surrounded by russian forces
but they also chose not to fight the
local crimeans were mobilized to go to
ukrainian military bases
to a prevent from any ukrainian troops
or soldiers to leave the base and when
they were given order from kiev to
to basically mount resistance many of
the commanders were saying but we cannot
mount resistance against civilians they
were
probably not aware of the time that
these civilians were mobilized by the by
the russian
special force operations to give them a
freeway
on the 25th of february a crowd of
pro-russian demonstrators
surrounded the crimean parliament
demanding a referendum
on joining russia what moscow described
as a legitimate referendum
took place on the 16th of march though
there was no option
on the ballot for crimea to keep its
status as part of ukraine
russia claimed 97 of the votes they
announced the referendum
and there was no choice for people but
basically either to stay home or to
comply with the occupational authorities
it was taking place
under the under the gun um this whole
sham sergey markov has a different view
it was a will of the crimean people
to leave ukraine and to join russia
president vladimir putin initially
denied his troops were involved in the
crimea operation
even as western intelligence agencies
were telling their governments that they
were
the smoke and mirrors appeared to be
enough to make
certain members of the nato military
alliance hesitate
instead of acting to stop the unfolding
land grab
crimea seems to be a really good example
of
how tools of the grey zone used to a
level
can can change the facts on the ground
kia giles again
absolutely uh before the conflict is
actually declared
part of the aim is presenting a fate
accompli presenting the facts before you
even get to fighting about them
and of course the reason why it remains
in what we might call the gray zone so
it remains below the threshold of open
armed conflict
is primarily because nobody has decided
to say that this is actually an act of
war things didn't go so smoothly though
when russia backed separatists started
rising up
in parts of eastern ukraine against the
government in kiev
as ms lutzewicz explains russians
had a strategy to prevent ukraine from
moving
closer to euro-atlantic structures to
becoming part of nato
becoming member of european union so
what they did right after their next
crimea they moved
moved up north if you want and they
started
this fermenting protest in odessa in
harkeef and
the first big city that they took over
was
uh in months after the annexation called
slavyansk
so this whole project of russian spring
as it was called
was meant to show that the people of
south east of ukraine are against uh
western vector for ukraine they are
against kiev
a report by the rand think tank
describes how russia
rather than sending in special forces as
it did with crimea
instead tried to use a mix of local
activists
fringe political groups and businessmen
to create the instability
they also launched a significant
disinformation campaign
aimed at turning public opinion against
the kiev government
zaparova said groups describing
themselves
as non-governmental organizations or
ngos
would also spread the pro-kremlin
narrative over the following years
uh we can't see radiation but it really
affects our health
so information radiation or information
influence or the narratives or the
information warfare also influences our
hearts and minds
i really want to motivate people to
check the information that they consume
whether it's a tv or an online media or
a newspaper that they read or a magazine
that they read a goal of the separatists
in 2014
was to convince ukraine's government to
allow a federal system
that would give more power to the
regions and so greater influence to
russia
but this greyzone attempt alone to bring
about change
didn't work ukrainian security forces
arrested many of the rebels in a
standoff that turned violent
within months russia was sending weapons
and eventually troops across its border
to bolster separatist forces in what
descended
into a war zone we saw that in the use
of
russian artillery and russian unmanned
aerial vehicles
to target conventional ukrainian
military
general barons has given evidence about
the conflict
to the uk parliament and that was done
in a way
that you can't really deny a lot of
people
were killed and injured a lot of
equipment was was damaged
but it was done in a way that didn't
engage the international community who
were not
present military experts think russia
used the conflict in ukraine to try out
new techniques
this included combining military strikes
with information operations like sending
ominous text messages to ukrainian
troops
about how their bodies would be found in
the snow
at the same time as targeting them with
artillery rounds
the chaos of war also brought
international tragedy
you're watching sky news it is five
o'clock british summer time here
in london and staying with this breaking
news story tonight
dramatic story that it appears that
a malaysian airlines plane may have been
shot
down and the incident seems to have
happened
close to the border between ukraine and
russia
some 50 kilometers short of the russian
border short of russian airspace
on the 17th of july 2014 malaysia
airlines flight mh17
traveling from amsterdam to kuala lumpur
was shot down
over rebel-held territory in eastern
ukraine
all 298 people on board were killed
a dutch-led team of investigators said
the surface-to-air missile system
used in the attack came from russia the
kremlin denies involvement
but evidence including audio messages
and images
has emerged to undermine the credibility
of these denials
so the facts are clear but they are
still
denied and that is i think just a
feature of how you operate in the gray
zone
and it's not new if you think back to
things that occurred for example in the
second world war which were terrible
which to this day the facts are clear
but they're still denied there's nothing
there's nothing really
new about this and and the issue is
really
not that it's denied it's just it's just
what is it that the rest of the world is
prepared to do about this
there were harsher sanctions against
russia in response to the downing of
mh17
and more support for the ukrainian armed
forces
but none of this was enough to bring
about an end to the wider crisis
there is even no tangible ceasefire now
that it's
almost seven years and i believe around
14 000
people died in in donbass in this war ms
litzewicz again
right now they only managed to control
two cities two
uh big regional cities of donetsk and
luhansk
and they are creating some kind of a
proxy state
that uh that resembles more soviet union
you know with the ideology of the soviet
glory with them
and it became this kind of a gray zone
for four million
people that live there which means
they're unrecognized by
ukraine they're unrecognized even by
russia
can you just explain like how you see uh
the military of the future that can deal
and that can fight in the gray zone
i'm back with general carter the uk's
military chief
it's a military first of all that's got
to be clearly modernized because it's a
military that's got to be able to
deter the sorts of capabilities that our
opponents have developed over the last
10 or 15 years
so i talked about subsurface stuff in
the maritime
domain i talked about electronic warfare
being linked with drones being linked
with
long-range missile systems to defeat
tanks
and so armored vehicles on battlefields
i talked about anti-access denial
systems
all of these capabilities that they've
developed have got to be countered in
one way or the other doesn't mean you
have to match them but you have to
counter them
because if you don't counter them you
won't have got deterrence in place
general carter and other military
commanders talk a lot
about modernization because much of the
uk's military equipment
is either out of date or in need of an
upgrade
the defense chief spoke to me at the end
of september 2020
a few weeks later the government
announced a decision to allocate
an extra 16.5 billion pounds to the
armed forces
over the next four years clearly good
news for the general
in fact it amounts to the biggest
investment in defence since the cold war
but there will still need to be painful
decisions to cut
or reduce capabilities and most likely
troop numbers
to free up cash to ensure all remaining
equipment
like warships jets and tanks are fit
for 21st century warfare where being
able to use
data is arguably as important as being
able to fire weapons
the ministry of defense must also invest
much more aggressively in future
technologies
which will involve taking risks on
projects
that will likely fail until one succeeds
in the past this whole area of
innovation
in my opinion has been way too under
ambitious
largely because the bulk of
overstretched defence spending
has been locked into legacy equipment
programs like aircraft carriers and fast
jets it's a massive challenge
and means a fundamental adjustment in
the entire military mindset
putting technology and data alongside
or even ahead of big metal objects
and it's not just about equipment it's
also
about how you use your people and the
first lesson
of prevailing in the gray zone is to
make sure you've got deterrence set
and therefore you are able to do to them
what they wouldn't like to have done to
them
so that's the first thing you have to do
the second thing you have to do i think
is to try and find ways of preventing
them from achieving their objectives
using
what i've described in the past as fate
accomplished strategies
and then it requires you to adopt a sort
of campaigning
style of approach to how you deal with
those threats
rather than sort of a series of tactical
responses
you've got to think from the status quo
back to the risk
and then work your way through that in a
much more strategic way than perhaps
we've been accustomed to
during the course of the cold war so
that kind of a change of mindset really
so it's not like it's not as if we're on
ops and then back off and it's like ah
relax so it's it's a change
to get you can't so you can't have a
peace mentality anymore
you need to be constantly uh alert and
and and competing is that yes it is so
so
what we might in the past have called an
exercise is actually telegraphing
a statement of intent or it is being
used for other purposes
and therefore what you have to do is to
recognize that that is
actually a small tactical battle in this
longer term campaign
which is about trying to have an impact
upon your opponent what he's talking
about
is a pretty significant shift in the way
the armed forces are used
instead of a distinction between being
on an operational tour
somewhere like iraq or afghanistan and
then being back at home
now any kind of training or exercise
either in the uk or abroad is viewed as
a way
to send a message in the gray zone to
adversaries
so what we've got to do i think in this
competition that we're discussing
is to work out how we can put boots on
the ground uh
to achieve the sort of presence that
will prevent vacuums from being created
for your opponents to fill but do so in
such a way that you manage the risk of
casualties
in a way that is acceptable to public
opinion and to policymakers
appetite for taking risk in the
industrial age the west very much had
the advantage they were the most they
had the most powerful militaries
um are you worried that that's changing
you know that that actually there is a
risk that
the this western dominance isn't by
right and actually could be
um overmatched by uh countries like
china developing
a technological advantage that could
then mean that they would be able to
just
you know outmatch us in all different
domains
uh definitely um i mean i think we see
that i mean china is a
an extraordinary country for innovation
and technological innovation for that
matter
and of course there is always um in
the character of warfare a constant
competition
between opposing technologies to try and
get match or overmatch
so the answer is yes that is definitely
something that needs to be
understood and dealt with you talk about
how like so the armed forces
obviously they exist to defend the
nation
um and and our allies and our interests
um but when it's like the the nation's
minds
that are under attack and when it's the
the institutions the pillars
of our democracy so the judiciary the
press
um that our government are our freedom
to elect
and our freedom to speak when it's that
that's being undermined
in the gray zone how can the military
help to defend that um
well first thing to recognize of course
is that the military can only play a
supporting role in this
because ultimately it's going to take
other government departments and other
instruments of statecraft
to protect it and i think all we can
really do
is to make sure that our part in all of
that
is as professionally delivered as it
possibly can be and that we are very
clear
a point the secretary state is often
making about the threat and you know we
do act as
a conscience as one would do as part of
the nation's
insurance policy to make sure people
understand the threat
and then clearly it's up to us to lobby
to make sure that that threat is dealt
with
in a proper holistic way and what can
people do
what's your message to people listening
to this podcast
because you're talking about a gray zone
you know the front line
everybody's on it no one's too
unimportant to be targeted in this gray
zone
can you just speak to people what do
they what should how should they
act what should they be aware of how can
they build their own resilience
um i mean i think my starting point is
to uh
is for people to recognize how lucky we
are to live in the sort of society that
i've certainly grown up in and you have
as well and that protecting the
values that that society represents and
the openness associated with it
is all of our jobs and tasks as
individual members of this country
and i think that's the starting point
for all of that then i think you know
there needs to be
a genuine desire by people to be
reconsidered in what they believe
and to think pretty hard about where
that news is coming from and what it
actually means
um and then you know if it's the wrong
news
it's fake news if it's disinformation to
call it out
and we should be up to calling it out
because ultimately
it undermines everything that we all
stand for
so you've more than four decades in in
the military how has your thinking
about the threat and the utility of
force
and how force needs to be calibrated
how has that changed from then to now
now when i was growing up it was very
black and white who the enemy was
and our total focus in military terms
was on defeating the enemy
and we coined a term called the
maneuverous approach which essentially
gave you the tools to get after that
enemy what
has changed since then is that the
environment now
has probably produced and introduced
multiple actors that need to be thought
about as well
and a lot of that is down to the
pervasiveness of information so if
you're
gonna go after the enemy first of all
you need to be really clear who the
enemy is
then you need to be really clear about
the other actors that are going to
influence you achieving that objective
whether that's the local population
whether it's the support of the
population back home whether it's
allies and partners that you're working
with to achieve the outcome
there will be a range of different
actors that you need to think about
and therefore it's become a much more
complex process working out how you
achieve your
objectives the objectives now in this
murky
information influenced world are
much harder to understand and to get
after
it's become more complicated it means
this
absolutely cannot just be a challenge
for the armed forces
it's one for the whole of the government
and every single person in the country
to be alive to
it's changing the way the most secret
parts of the state
think and operate too for the first time
ever
two members of mi5 the uk security
service
who tackle the threat posed by russia
have agreed to an interview
to talk about their work
tom and kate met me at mi5's
little-known
underground museum at their headquarters
in central london
tom came to the meeting with a small
black box in one hand
he placed it on a table as we said hello
and then suggested i open it
but that's next time as we continue into
the gray zone
[Music]
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from sophia
mcbride and michael greenfield
and narrated by me debra haynes
the head of sky news radio is dave
terrace
[Music]
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts
you